i want to take a look at our two op-amp
circuits and make an interesting
observation about how these things are
behaving when they are working properly
when they're hooked up right there's
something these things do
that is really helpful and makes life
simple for us
let's let the gain of our op amp be 10
to the third or 10 to the sixth really
high gained a million
and we're going to let the output
voltage here v out
let's say 6 volts
and you remember what's not shown here
in this circuit is is the
is the power supply is going to both of
these op amps
plus or minus let's say it's plus or
minus 12 volts
those power supplies are implicit
they're not shown in the diagram but we
know they're there
all right now if v out is 6 volts and a
is 10 to the 6 then what's v in vn is
the difference between these two
voltages here
let's call this the usual thing we'll
call this v plus
and we'll call this v minus
and we know that v n
we know that v n
equals v plus minus v minus
and now what the question is what is v n
in terms of v out well v n
equals v out
divided by a
if we fill in the values we had it's six
volts
divided by ten to the sixth
or
six microvolts
so this is six microvolts between here
and here
okay so with with six volts here there's
six micro volts over here okay this is a
really small voltage
in order for this
uh op-amp to have a output voltage that
stays between plus or minus 12 volts
this voltage over here has to be really
small it has to be down to the micro
volts level
so because i'm a practical engineer i'm
just going to say this is
pretty much zero volts
and if i say this is zero that's pretty
much the same thing as saying that v
plus
approximately equals
v minus
so that's a little observation we're
going to make right there
so in this circuit when it's working
right these two voltages are pretty much
the same
so let's take this idea v plus pretty
much equals v minus
and apply it to this circuit over here
now this is our inverting configuration
for an op amp
so this is v plus
and this is v minus in this circuit
and let's do the same analysis that we
did before if this is v out
and if v out is 6 volts
that means that
v plus minus v minus
divided by 10 to the 6
equals 6 micro volts
and that says that this
is six micro volts
in this direction
when we did this over here
because the signs of the inputs are
flipped this was six micro volts this
way
so again because of the enormous gain of
this this amplifier this is always going
to be a tiny tiny number and so heck why
not make it zero
so if i treat this as zero what it means
is i'm going to go right in here
and i'm going to change this
to
zero volts
so let's make a couple more observations
okay right now it says right here v plus
equals zero
because it's grounded so what does that
mean v minus is
well v minus is also zero
v minus is zero
so that point right there
is at 0 volts
okay so that's pretty cool so
that points at 0 volts now is it
connected to ground
it's not connected to ground but it's
zero volts because of what this op-amp
is doing for us this op-amp is making
sure by this feedback path
that this node is always next to this
node and that means it's always zero
there's a really cool word that we use
for this and the word is
virtual
and what does the word virtual mean well
virtual means that something is not
there
but it seems like it is
so in this case this node is not
connected to ground but it seems like it
is so this is referred to as a
a virtual ground
so these two ideas say the same thing
v plus equals v minus is always the
situation around the input to an op-amp
when it's running properly
and in the case particularly of this
op-amp configuration where the plus
terminal is connected to ground we say
that the other terminal v minus
is at a virtual ground or is a virtual
ground
in the next video i'm going to go back
and do this inverting configuration of
the op amp i'm going to do the analysis
again with this idea of a virtual ground
and it's going to be really easy
compared to doing all that algebra